[Music]
Hello, how are you? Natalia Lancelot greets you
and with her brief informative for today,
Friday, July 9, Nevada offers 5
million reasons for people to get
vaccinated and participate in a raffle where
multiple prizes are awarded. The first
round of winners happened.  last night more than
200 people were selected
where most of the prizes were
large sums of money to be able to
participate in the
new bucks incentive program la dates the state asks
you to have at least one dose of
the coronavirus vaccine prizes will be
awarded  until august 26
you are looking for a job this might
interest you pay attention there will be a big
job fair today inside the
las vegas convention center this event
starts at 9 in the morning and
runs until 2 in the afternoon there
will be more  of 100 companies looking to
hire more than 12,000 people
you can fill out your application
in advance at the big carrier center or
simply attend  Good luck to the center
this weekend to Las Vegas
prepare for a great night it will be the
fight of webs and 264 trilogy between with
gun gray dear temporis inside the
scam bull flour
the mexicana and aldana will also return to the octagon as part
of the undercard of  that night and this
is not all since argentina and brazil
will face each other in the final of the copa
america also mexico will have its first
gold cup match on saturday
night for sports lovers and they
have a choice and now we move on
to the weather forecast we are in the
middle of an extreme heat wave
temperatures will be even higher
than normal we will reach 115
degrees by this afternoon and get ready
because by the weekend it will be
hotter extreme heat alert will
remain until monday nice
friday
me  I'm Natalia Lanzelotti and this was your
brief news report on Inés Now in Spanish
[Music]